we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p speaking of
people misunderstanding what i say
here's someone who asks why am IA
centrist neoliberal shill hey David um I
just want to know why are you supporting
Jordan Peterson by supporting his be
right-wing Network spot or whatever the
[ __ ] is called right why are you such a
centrist neoliberal show thank you thank
you very much appreciate it so listen I
addressed the thing but I think the spot
thing yesterday I'm not gonna do it
again I have taken every political
spectrum and compass test that anybody
has sent me I am more to the left than I
have ever been before over the last ten
years I've taken those tests many times
on the David Pakman show and every
single time I end up further to the left
so that's me pretending to take the
voicemail seriously we've got a great
bonus show today Russia has been banned
from the Olympics in global sports for
four years over doping former White
House physician Ronnie Jackson is gonna
run for Congress and there's an
interesting bill in the house which
could lower patients prescription drug
spending significantly and we will talk
about that and much more on the bonus
show get access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at join pakman.com or
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show